je sais pas vous mais moi il y a trois
choses que j'ai pas du tout envie de
voir arriver trop tôt l'hiver la mort et
l'éjaculation philosophiquement parlant
c'est intéressant parce que bon bah
l'hiver j'aime pas trop ça c'est long
c'est froid la mort j'aime pas trop ça
non plus c'est long c'est froid alors
que l'éjaculation j'aime bien ça c'est
ni froid ni long c'est même l'inverse en
fait c'est plutôt chaud c'est c'est trop
c'est trop court souvent c'est alors je
sais pas du tout où je vais bref on
n'est pas là pour parler de philo de
toute façon par contre on va parler
d'éjaculation précoce ça oui on va faire
ça allez allez hop
[Musique]
donc aujourd'hui on va parler
d'éjaculation précoce parce que vous
allez voir que c'est une dysfonction
sexuelle très répandue mais dans une
prochaine vidéo on parlera aussi de
vaginisme d'ailleurs s'il y a d'autres
thèmes dont vous avez envie que je parle
hésitez pas vous savez quoi faire mais
avant de commencer un petit message et
des cadeaux cette vidéo est sponsorisée
par les lots les lots vous les
connaissez bien maintenant si vous êtes
des habitués ils ont sponsorisé
plusieurs de mes vidéos sur la santé
sexuelle ils vendent des sextoys de
qualité construit dans des matériaux de
qualité pour du sexe de qualité qui sent
bon le beurre de karité pas du tout
qu'est-ce que je raconte tout est vrai
sauf le beurre de karité alors il y a
plusieurs choses à savoir d'abord on est
au mois de mai merci Einstein
laissez-moi finir le 7 mai c'était la
journée internationale de la
masturbation j'espère que vous avez été
gâté et que les cloches sont bien
passées attendez je crois que je
confonds bref tout au long du mois de
mai c'est le mois de la masturbation
chez les lots du coup jusqu'au 7 juin
pour toute commande de plus de 189 euros
avec le code DTC spring les lots et moi
on vous offre un sauna pas un bain de
vapeur un sauna avec un c'est un de
leurs Banger c'est un stimulateur
clitoridien je pense que vous oui voilà
ça c'est un sauna 2 Cruz la version
encore améliorée du fameux sauna
rien à voir avec Tom Cruise par contre
ça veut dire croisière une croisière
vers le plaisir ensuite il y a une
sélection d'articles en promotion comme
celui-là par exemple le Enigma Cruz
celui-là il stimule le clitoris et le
point G double croisière
là
mais il y a aussi de quoi stimuler le
pénis évidemment il y a de quoi stimuler
tout ce que vous avez envie de stimuler
c'est pas dur allez faire un tour sur
leur site et si vous trouvez votre
bonheur n'oubliez pas le code DTC spring
qui vous permettra d'avoir un flacon de
lubrifiant ou un spray nettoyant pour
sextoys en cadeau et puis en parlant de
cadeau avec les lots on vous propose de
vous faire gagner un Enigma Cruz
celui-là vous vous rappelez double
croisière pour participer il vous suffit
de commenter cette vidéo avec le texte
suivant double croisière
exactement comme ça sinon ça ne marche
pas et puis plus tard je ferai un petit
tirage au sort pour le reste je vous
mets le lien vers le site de l'ELO dans
la description allez faire un tour et
faites-vous plaisir littéralement allez
c'est parti pour l'éjaculation précoce
enfin je vous avez compris est-ce que
l'éjaculation précoce c'est un vrai truc
et ben oui non
[Musique]
oui parce que ça touche 30 % des
propriétaires de pénis à un moment ou un
autre de leur vie voire plus il y a même
un sondage qui parle d'un homme sur deux
et non parce que bien souvent on utilise
le terme alors que c'est pas vraiment de
ça dont il s'agit et puis surtout parce
que c'est pas du tout une fatalité vous
allez voir et c'est pas une maladie non
plus hein c'est ce qu'on appelle une
dysfonction sexuelle une expression un
peu flippante pour dire que ça se passe
pas comme on voudrait donc ça existe
c'est même fréquent mais c'est quelque
chose de précis donc faut pas employer
le mot à temps et à travers d'ailleurs
puisqu'on en a parlé de mots on dit
quasiment plus et éjaculation précoce on
dit éjaculation prématurée ou
éjaculation rapide
mais c'est quoi exactement alors
concrètement une éjaculation précoce une
éjaculation rapide ça a trois
caractéristiques déjà elle arrive
rapidement après la pénétration
il y a pas vraiment de durée officielle
mais on parle d'une minute voire deux
maximum et parfois ça peut même arriver
avant la pénétration deuxièmement il y a
une notion d'impossibilité à se
contrôler elle arrive sans que ce soit
possible de se retenir si vous voulez et
troisièmement c'est vécu négativement
par l'un ou l'autre des partenaires
ou les deux bien sûr ou bon bref donc
vous voyez c'est des trucs très objectif
et puis il y a quand même une notion un
petit peu subjective qui est celle de
l'insatisfaction et puis il y en a
plusieurs types on parle d'éjaculation
rapide primaire si elle a toujours
existé et de Seconde Guerre bah si elle
est apparue dans un second temps et puis
un petit peu comme on avait vu avec la
norgasmine elle peut être permanente ou
intermittente elle peut arriver que
pendant les rapports sexuels mais pas
pendant la masturbation etc etc il y a
plein de cas de figure en fait comment
ça marche pas bien en fait il peut y
avoir des causes physiques comme un
pénis trop sensible par exemple
des sensations physiques les nerfs tout
ça je parle pas d'un pénis drama queen
ça peut aussi être la conséquence d'un
problème comme une inflammation de la
prostate par exemple mais on peut se le
dire dans l'immense majorité des cas la
cause elle est psychologique et
émotionnelle et encore une fois on peut
pas dire que ce soit une maladie parce
que à la base physiologiquement on est
comme les autres animaux on est
programmé pour éjaculer le plus vite
possible vu qu'au départ le but c'est
juste de procréer bah oui parce que
pendant qu'on est occupé à faire notre
petit business là on est quand même
particulièrement vulnérable et du coup
on risque de se faire bouffer par un
prédateur donc hop c'est bonjour madame
au revoir madame on va laisser peser
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui explique que le
stress ça provoque où ça aggrave des
éjaculations rapides bah oui parce que
les hormones du stress comme
l'adrénaline par exemple au départ le
rôle c'était de nous mettre en condition
pour faire face à un danger donc
aujourd'hui encore si pour une raison ou
pour une autre on se met la pression
pendant un coït BIM monter d'hormones du
stress notre corps il pense qu'on va se
faire grailler et il nous dit mais tu
vas convaincre personne avec ton machin
là donc tu finis ta petite tu viens de
battre ou tu t'en suis et du coup hop
le sperme
en réalité le principal problème c'est
une difficulté voire une incapacité à
contrôler son excitation c'est aussi
simple que ça est-ce que c'est
irréversible pas le film je veux dire
est-ce que c'est
non pas du tout mais alors pas du tout
du tout justement il y a plein de gens
qui croient ça et ça fait même partie du
problème parce que vous allez voir
qu'une des clés c'est d'être serein vu
que quand on anticipe le fait d'avoir
une éjaculation précoce ça nous stresse
et que plus on est stressé plus on a de
chances d'avoir une éjaculation précoce
donc c'est le serpent qui se
voyait il y a même des gens qui
finissent par éviter d'avoir des
rapports sexuels par peur que ça leur
arrive alors que là encore c'est pareil
moins on le fait souvent plus ça change
d'arriver alors un petit truc comme ça
vous avez remarqué comment on définit
l'éjaculation précoce ça tient compte
uniquement de ce qu'on appelle le temps
de latence de l'éjaculation c'est-à-dire
le temps qui s'écoule entre la
pénétration et l'éjaculation encore un
truc qui part du principe qu'un rapport
sexuel ça avec la pénétration et ça se
termine avec l'éjaculation et ça c'est
quelque chose qui en plus de faire
complètement passer au second plan le
plaisir et l'orgasme de plus de la
moitié de l'humanité celle qui possède
une vulve et un vagin bah ça donne une
importance démesurée à l'éjaculation et
si ce matin
avec notamment pour conséquence bah tout
ce dont on parle le plus tout à l'heure
donc faut peut-être commencer par
désacraliser l'éjaculation et faire
tomber le tabou de l'éjaculation rapide
aussi bien sûr il faut en parler en fait
il faut ni avoir peur ni avoir honte et
comment ça soigne déjà on va dire qu'il
y a pas à soigner puisque c'est pas une
maladie ça va détendre tout le monde on
va dire que ça se contrôle plutôt et du
coup oui il y a plein de techniques pour
maîtriser tout ça on peut apprendre à
maîtriser les muscles de son périnée
c'est-à-dire de son bas-ventre pour
retarder l'éjaculation il y a des
exercices à faire pour ça on peut
apprendre à gérer ces mouvements pendant
le rapport sexuel pour pas que ça monte
trop vite on peut apprendre à maîtriser
son excitation à se détendre aussi à pas
se mettre la pression parce que c'est
quand même beaucoup de ça dont il s'agit
ça veut dire relâcher la pression
mentale et physique les deux plus on est
relâché mentalement mais aussi
physiquement au niveau des muscles et
notamment des fameux muscles du périnée
plus on retarde l'éjaculation l'idée
c'est d'apprendre à lâcher prise et
aussi d'apprendre à mieux se connaître
pour être capable de se contrôler
d'ailleurs pour ça la masturbation ça
peut aussi être un moyen et en attendant
que tout ça ça marche s'il y a besoin il
y a même des médicaments qui peuvent
retarder l'éjaculation alors ok mais
comment on fait tout ça bah vous allez
trouver plein d'articles et plein de
tutos des trucs que vous pouvez faire
pour vous exercer en dehors et pendant
les rapports sexuels des exercices de
respiration et de méditation des tips
plus pratiques etc etc ça c'est facile
et ça peut marcher sans problème mais si
ça suffit pas et que vous avez besoin de
quelque chose de plus personnalisé et de
plus pousser par exemple et ben il faut
aller voir des professionnels de santé
en solo ou avec vos partenaires parce
que c'est plus efficace si c'est géré à
deux médecins sexologue psychologue
spécialisé kiné spécialisé oui les kinés
spécialisés ça existe aussi mais pour ça
il faut avoir une ordonnance en gros
c'est ni plus ni moins que de la
rééducation sexuelle et puis
souvenez-vous de quatre trucs déjà
l'éjaculation précoce ça touche un homme
sur trois à un moment ou un autre de sa
vie ça ça aide à relativiser pas mal
ensuite comme chien de le dire il y a
plein de solutions qui marchent très
bien pour régler ça donc ça c'est pour
donner un petit peu d'ESP oir ensuite il
y a une étude qui a été menée sur 500
couples qui se sont chronométrés pendant
les rapports sexuels oui c'est beau la
science et la durée médiane du fameux
temps de latence dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure vous vous souvenez c'est
5,4 minutes donc c'est pas Avatar 2 non
plus et ça varié de 33 secondes à 44
minutes donc je pense qu'on peut
considérer qu'il y a pas de norme comme
[Musique]
il faut juste que ce soit satisfaisant
pour tout le monde et puis surtout pour
finir il faut arrêter de penser que
l'éjaculation c'est le truc le plus
important dans un rapport sexuel vous
êtes au moins deux déjà dans cette
histoire comme
il peut se passer plein de trucs avant
il peut se passer plein de trucs après
donc relax avec ça voilà DTC c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui continuer à m'envoyer
vos questions à question
dtc@gmail.com je vais bientôt faire une
session de questions-réponses je sais
pas encore si ce sera sur twitch ou sur
insta Tik Tok etc donc abonnez-vous pour
être sûr de pas rater ça et puis on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]